computer science has had a home at
Carnegie Mellon for more than 50 years
our students faculty and alumni have
built a tradition of innovation
collaboration and problem solving with
the Gate Center for computer science and
hillman Center for future generation
technologies we are connecting to this
tradition on a whole new level
we are opening the doors to a new home
buildings for people as well as
technology a place for breakthrough work
for far-reaching explorations that push
the boundaries of knowledge and develop
life-changing tools and applications the
gates and Hillman centers will be the
heart of computer science learning and
research at Carnegie Mellon with
classrooms and study spaces cafes and
meeting spaces collaborative workspaces
lots of natural light and windows and
bridges connecting us to our colleagues
and friends across the campus and in the
community in the gates and Hillman
centers hard work imagination and
innovation will connect on a whole new
level
this is the future of computer science
at Carnegie Hall this is the future of
computer science for the world this is
my future my future my future this is
our future